[Music]
okay guys today is such an exciting day
I am getting a brand new car finally so
I've had my 2010 Honda Civic since 2010
so it's a pretty old car it's been
failing on me it's already reached the
100,000 mile and so they say you know I
went to your car reach of that you
should probably get a new car
so today's finally of the day that I'm
getting my friend new car and I'm just
so excited this car is a car I've wanted
for a really long time the most exciting
part for me today is seeing Isaac's
reaction to the new car because he wants
this car like 10 times more than I want
it so yeah like that's that's how much
he wants this car so we're gonna be
picking him up early from school he'd
has no idea what's happening I've
actually been waiting for this car for
about a whole month and so this month
has been the longest month of my life
because I'm like God I just want this
car already I want to be driving it
around and like just enjoying it already
so it's been like the longest month ever
but right now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna clean out my old Honda Civic baby
and just prepare it for me to say
farewell it's actually been my first car
that I've ever gotten like straight from
the dealership and so I was really proud
of that car cuz it looks like you know
we had like this bonding moment of like
oh you're my first car and I've had it
for the past eight years it's gonna be a
little sad letting go of it but I'm just
way more excited for the new car so I
don't know it's like bittersweet you
know so here she is my Honda Civic I've
had to for many years you've gone
through so much with me I remember Isaac
was 2 years old when I got this car he
had just turned 2 so I remember his car
seats in the back to seeing him grow up
and like grow out of like the bigger car
see where he's like front-facing to him
going into a booster seat and then
now being such a big kid you could even
sit in the front like I don't know it's
just you know seeing like stages of my
child through this car it's a pretty
sentimental for me I also have Isaac's
bracelet he made a bracelet for me when
he was in preschool have it in the
center console here there was this other
bracelet too and he dropped it somewhere
so I'm hoping I could find that bracelet
right now when I clean out my car again
and this bear I bought my car in
February of 2010 so the car dealership
gave me this little bear with a heart on
it as kind of like a congratulations on
your new car kind of thing and I've had
it here all these years
like all these years I've had my cards
that bear has lived there I got to clean
this up oh man I'm actually getting sad
I'm letting go this car that's kind of
weird let's focus on the happy though
I'm gonna get a new cut yay a new car
okay all right I gotta clean this out oh
man this is weird
I remember I bought this thing when I
first got the car - I bought it at the
dollar store I remember being so like
super careful to make sure that my car
was always clean my cab dashboard
I would always clean it like this I'd be
like oh yeah my baby it has to stay nice
and clean and I haven't haven't done
that in ages so I stopped caring about
this car right so Casey's gonna help me
sell my boy
what's early on my car it's funny
because I'm using the honey-bag to sing
it out just so you guys know I'm not
getting the Hyundai I really want that
fantasy though but hold on said you
didn't tell them what are you getting
yeah I didn't tell them yet
and then I don't want to put in the
title either so they're gonna find out
later with Isaac Quinto watch a trade in
his car for an SUV or like a crossover
because the car I'm getting is still a
sedan it's gonna be that big yeah like
for that SUV thing I'm still considering
getting that Santa Fe like I want you to
be happy too so you don't want the
Hyundai there no worries you really want
me to be happy yeah let me get a
forerunner or a cheap Wrangler sure if
you want to be happy then you get what
you want I'm very happy today with what
happened getting now we can't get the
Jeep or four runners because of this
right here alone this door is very very
low and any tall like full-size SUVs are
gonna be able to fit in this garage and
we're not trying to park on streaks
because we're so far from the street
takes a bit of a walk to get to the
street over here so we're embedded into
our complex yeah so I'm thinking the
Santa Fe could fit here oh you don't
want it true Santa Fe could fit in here
it's a very small icy yeah but Santa Fe
I don't know I mean it's a cool car
don't get me wrong but it's just not as
cool of a car as the one that it's gonna
get and I kind of want to get a car
that's you know just as cool so so we
could be on the same cool school you
know what
who says cool school I don't know get
rind so I liked it hi everybody before
you hand didn't get the camera you're
telling me that you were getting
emotional
he said yeah when I was I mean they know
they already saw that part but did you
talk like right no I didn't cry it's
just like thinking about me letting go
this it's because like so I started
thinking about when I got this car eight
years ago and I was like so happy so
excited because I like I was going
through a really rough time in my life
like I had just started my hospital gig
Isaac was 2 years old and I was in a
relationship that was pretty controlling
and so like he would kind of
hang that over my head when I didn't
have a car like oh you know I'm not
gonna take you there unless you
apologize for this argument that I just
made up like it was just really
manipulative and so like the day that I
got this car we had gotten into a fight
and I had just left and I went with my
girlfriend to the Honda dealer and we
signed all the papers and everything but
I needed something from my wallet but
this dude he actually took my wallet
from me that day he was like no you're
not getting a new car you would use that
to manipulate me to get me to say or do
what he wanted like for example I need
her to go to work I just started this
hospital gig I can't be like I'm not
gonna take you to work until you do this
or until you say that so I felt so stuck
and so like in a really bad place right
so the day that I got this car I went
back and so I told him like I'm getting
this hard I don't care what you do like
you can't stop me I'm getting this car
so somehow I was able to get my wallet
and I went back to the dealership and I
signed
oh wait like I don't even know go she
ate I didn't say anything I was just
like just give me this car like you
wanted to life again like I just felt
like this would be my final like I could
be free like my happiness sure to get to
Liberty right here yeah so that's my
like this car means a lot to me oh my
god getting that yeah just I remember
like loving it so much yeah I don't know
it was up it was a hard time in my life
and this car came to the rescue
so
means a lot making me tear up
right yeah hey it's good memories we're
gonna make better memories in the new
one I'm excited for the new one
definitely exciting but just it's sad
I always keep napkins in my glove
compartment the only time I've ever
cried for a car was I think I was
probably six or seven and my parents
were getting rid of their Mazda I think
it was the nine to nine I don't even
know if that model exists anymore and I
was not having it a day the the buyers
came to pick it up those people they are
not leaving my best friend this back
seat means everything to me I've dropped
sodas here I've dropped chicken nuggets
back there I even have a crevice for all
the crumbs where I'm gonna eat later it
was like the only facts that I've ever
known like I don't think ever my parents
ever drove me in another car back then
other than that one so like it was a
huge deal I could relate to you TIFF I
didn't think it I don't think I mean I
knew this car meant a lot to me but I
don't think I meant this much to me now
that I have to let it go all right clean
away
don't think everything in handle let's
do it gonna be even more set I found it
it's the bracelet I told you guys Isaac
made for me when he was in preschool I
had it here for years and years and
years until a few months ago when Isaac
was looking at it and he dropped it I
just found it under the seat so I'm
happy I found it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so this baby is nice and clean
is the cleanest it's gonna get before I
say goodbye to it and I'm actually
running out of gas so I'm not gonna make
it to the place where I have to go pick
up my car so this is actually gonna be
the last time I pump gas in my own car
so that's a clue for which car I'm
getting well that's how I'm coming s in
my car this is so weird here we go all
right we are on our way and oh yeah I
think there was nothing hey Isaac how
was your day at school it was good
Oh would you tell him so far so I didn't
know that he knew that I was picking him
up early so I asked him I'm like are you
surprised that I'm thinking of early he
was like no Teddy told me he might be
picking me up early because you know
it's Friday want to get out earlier then
I started rushing and then he was like
are we going somewhere I was like maybe
and I'm like something like that so then
now he's like are we going so he has no
idea what do you think give me your wow
this guesses no could he could he ask
some questions sure how about you get
five questions are we going super far
yeah is it in Los Angeles yes
is it near the JK office no no you're
running out of question that's three are
you gonna be there with friends no no
[Music]
have we been here before no no
[Music]
but all five yeah that was five well I
mean you're gonna find out in about 52
minutes also if you look around you
might get another clue as to what
exactly is happening but I don't think
you're gonna get it try to scope out the
place yeah no well you just looked
around you didn't see anything different
no no you didn't see anything that was
different around you daddy
Jirka no right now look at my clips
begin to your car wash this is a clue
right here and then I told you something
missing and I'm pointing in this area
like what do I usually have you have
like um the little ring thing that I
gave you and the teddy bear and the
little thing yeah so doing maybe that
thing yeah why would it be missing why
would that be missing somebody clean the
car or something I just got a car wash
the car is already clean yeah I got it
washed before picking you up are you
training it yep well you look are you
getting
Yosi we're trading this car in are we
getting you're gonna go find out you'll
find I'm full of Tesla you'll find out
you'll find that so yeah so this is your
last car ride in this car this is it
last time I'm driving this car giving
you a chance to say goodbye to this car
today
last time driving the car I've had this
car since you were 2 years old do you
remember being in the car this car is
inherited I didn't think that it would
be like really old by the time you could
drive but eventually maybe the next one
anymore
[Music]
we're very very close you excited or
would I am my heart is pounding
I don't know why I'd like them it's not
like everyday yeah I don't know like I'm
excited but nervous it's a serious man
every day buy a car so I think I'm
nervous because I'm sad
does that make sense yeah you have to
say goodbye to something you have to
lose a party and gain something you want
he's feeling the same thing too
we're one minute away these are weird
shapes what they say has a little T on
why they say wait please see mine though
I got white interior so earlier we were
talking about your dream car what's your
dream car well this car this car
actually technically the Model X take me
ya know X but yeah we don't have that
much money
any Tesla car you know what's crazy is
me and mommy have been talking about
wanting to get this car but really I
don't know there's other cars you could
possibly get and then you know what made
us decide to go with this one yep
[Music]
I want to get this car yeah it's the
Apple of cars can you believe that I
have that will car play I put it as
tight as possible you look so funny
there's actually the key to my car oh
cool I think I feel like I feel like a
James Bond or something I feel like I'm
some secret agent that has like a really
cool ten-week car that's like for spies
control my entire art from my phone uh
where I love being in the future I wish
I could talk to my younger self I'd be
like oh my god girlfriend your car is
gonna be so cool the future funny we got
a Tesla any sensitivity yeah do you for
my name and then my favorite number is
three the model 3 what's over there
[Music]
yeah
very excited Sun is the sunset golden
hour but lovely
as great
this is just like the most picturesque
moment of the day to get my brand-new
car I'm so excited I'm excited before
you you know why you know it's your car
- you're registered on it married what I
know I know but this is a feel like this
car matches you you're so into
technology and all these kinds of things
I'm not so it's more you got a winner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think Isaac
[Music]
how's it feel
[Music]
smells good in here I know he's your
dream car huh yep your Tesla taking care
of it okay get the Tahoe they said
there's really good quality it's
resistant to stains yeah it's really
stain resistant but I'm also gonna buy
some like thing from the bottom so it
doesn't stain with like the jeans
instead oh it's terrific gave us a
present look at this it's a different
color but actually was considering red
but runs too bright I really like the
way your car looks so the Midnight's
over on the outside and then the white
and black in your thighs so nice it's
pretty sick I know I'm so glad so I
ended up ordering it with black interior
because I was thinking you know future
the kids and they're gonna make it all
dirty
yeah just we never know so I'm just like
hah maybe I should get black I don't
think we should ever put the baby in
here when the baby happens it's a car
it's meant to be use it's not like I'm
not gonna treat this like like some like
trophy that needs to be so - no it's our
cards okay find your you got a point but
yeah for sure there's no eating or
drinking in here anyway so I started
thinking about it and then we went test
driving some other cars for your car to
be traded in and
and I we ended up test driving a car
that had like really white interior and
I was taking some photos inside of it
and I was just like oh my gosh I think I
messed up I should have gone the white
interior so then I contacted the guy
that sold this is Tesla and I'm like
anything is too late for me to change I
he's like no you can still change it I'm
like yeah I got white interior instead
you're for the ground it's so pretty cuz
it looks so pretty looking right now I'm
staring at the screen of the this camera
really yeah alright the car is all ours
and we're about to go celebrate where we
going we're gonna go eat some Japanese
food oh my gosh I'm driving my car oh my
gosh I'm driving my new car this car has
power this car drives so different since
it's an electric car it doesn't have
like that get the full power immediately
you're so strange
whoa and then I let go of the gas and
then it stops
[Music]
[Music]
you don't miss your old car now right
when it come up Civic to Tesla I'm
trying to get used to those regenerative
things as soon as I let go of the gas it
starts slowing down it's so weird it's
like a go-kart
that's how go-karts drive okay soon as I
let go you see you see I like how you're
in the middle he's just you want to see
the screen too and everything all right
so we pulled out and we realized we're
missing our garage door opener to the
house so he came back and our new car
and the old car got to meet good bye
Honda Civic
hello Tesla we actually forgot the
garage door opener so we had to come
back and then it was funny because
Casey's like look the cars are meeting
[Music]
we're transferring the energy of the old
car into this car now so we got it we
got the blessing we did we can feel good
about this yes Merry Christmas guys I'm
so happy that we can finally share with
you guys our Christmas presents the
dopest Christmas presents to ourselves
we've ever given - so exciting anyway
we're just super excited to share with
you guys that we love sharing our
memories with you guys and so if you
haven't heard already we just want to
let you
that we did launch our vlogging course
to teach you guys how we create our
blogs it's called life with the Kevin
calm and we get to show you guys the
methods that we use to create our books
yeah so we're running a New Year's promo
right now be sure to check it out before
it runs out on January 5th so this video
course has a very special place for me
my parents used to love videotaping
everything that me and my brother did
and just found like how we're doing with
Isaac right now and the thing that my
dad had always wanted to do with his
videos was to add music to it and edit
it and make these little cool home
videos but even never had the means to
edit you know you would shoot a whole
bunch but it was just hours and hours of
footage I know cuz every time we go to
your parents house will sit there cuz I
like watching Casey's baby videos cuz
you're so cute and I wish I had some
footage of myself when I was a baby as
well but yeah we'll sit there and watch
like hours of just raw footage of baby
Casey they're like young momma I'm a
little carry running around and just so
cute but there's a lot of things I
thought dad does it's exactly and so
that's pretty much the reason why Casey
wanted to create this course as well as
to help people like I said you know what
I should do is do a haul like 1989 vlog
that would be so cool cuz I have footage
from 1989 I was like a year old and my
parents were like Warren yeah so be sure
to check out life with a camera calm and
hope you guys have a very Merry Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas guys we'll see
you and like that the chemicals
[Music]